all right Brian
now where'd you grow up where are you
from originally
um I grew up in Alabama north Alabama
close to Huntsville and um moved around
a lot as a kid my mom and dad got
divorced when I was eight years old my
dad passed away a year after that he was
murdered
and then my mom went into an abusive
relationship where they were alcoholics
and everything so
other than that she was married to that
man for a year and then she ended up
finding my stepfather who my little
brothers by my little brother's 18 now
and he's in north Alabama college
but um due to my father being murdered
and going through seeing my mom abused
in the alcoholic relationship and
everything and and I was also abused
sexually with my
um cousin who's a lot older than me
it sort of gave me a downhill slide and
um I started doing drugs and I moved
around a lot and um so here I am in Los
Angeles I've been in on New York I've
been in Florida I lived in Texas
Mississippi Arkansas
um I've I've lived in um
Arizona for a while I lived in Arizona
for about seven years and now I'm out
here and just now recently got into an
apartment and starting to do better so
what is your drug
um meth is is been my downfall um I
smoke weed though
and you've been living on the streets
up until just recently getting housing
yes I've been moving so much that I
never stayed in one place long enough to
get a house
so this has been the longest I've been
in an area and tried for myself in a
long time what was your father murdered
over
um he was it was about a year after my
mom and dad got a divorce he was seeing
a woman trust he was a truck driver and
um he was seeing a lady who was a lady
truck driver and her divorce was a a
week to the day before it was Final and
he waited at my dad's work at like two
in the morning my dad had a key card
where he could clock himself in and go
in and everything and come back to his
truck there was no one at the business
and he waited at my dad's work and um
the cop said that he had to have started
his truck and then started back towards
the building
um and then come back towards the truck
because they found him in between he's
already clocked in they found him
between the building and my dad's truck
my dad's truck was running so they said
he had to have started the truck and
then went and clocked in and then on his
way back to God must have stepped out
from behind the truck and shot him shot
him right here and you know it got him
so sorry
and you uh
how have you been supporting yourself
while you've been on the streets
um in Florida I started prostituting and
um but I've been trying my best to do
Day Labor Day Labor um here I haven't
had to do that on prostitution but um
I've been doing day labor and using
my gr and all that stuff with general
relief for food stamps and I've been
trying to get get along with that as
best as I can and try to come out of all
the Badness that's been going on in my
life you know yeah did you finish High
School I got my GED and took two years
of carpentry
and you you dropped out of school at
what age
um I was in the seventh grade so around
16 or so and um I went back and did two
years of carpentry at a Career Technical
Institute
and so there's where I got my geds
looking back your life is there anything
you would have done differently if you
could have
I would have
knowing the things that had went wrong I
would have
told the people what was going to happen
like my father I'd have been like you
know don't go to work and that it was so
strange that that morning because I had
not missed school much in my whole life
and um
I was in Alabama and my father was
living in Mississippi and he kept me
that weekend and he was going to take me
to the eye doctor that Monday
and it was one of the very few days that
I had missed school and
um when he was leaving for work that
night I was crying to him I was like Dad
don't go don't go
some it was like a sixth sense a feeling
in my stomach something was going to
happen and that's the knot that he
passed away
so if it was anything I could do
differently I would just you know tell
the people who I've lost not to do the
things that they've done I would go
I would have a better life in that
aspect would have changed and I believe
that I could have and they could have
you know lived longer so and better
what is your biggest fear now
being alone I feel like I'm never going
to find somebody to love me for for
myself
because I don't feel like I love myself
you know
it's harder on the streets to even get
the self-worth the self-esteem to
feel like you deserve anyone in your
life or yeah even a job I talked to
myself I talked down to myself a lot and
I don't I've been trying to cut that out
um the past
a couple months since I've been here
I've been here uh three years in Los
Angeles but since I've gotten my
apartment now um it's been three months
since I've had my new apartment has that
helped you it does I it's furnished and
I got a TV and you know food I got food
and all that stuff but it's just I still
I'm talking down to myself Brian do you
deserve this Brian
what makes you think that you should be
off the streets when everybody that
you've always known since you've been
doing drugs is still out there you know
and I want to help people but you can't
help people who aren't helping
themselves you know
it's a real struggle to climb out of
this lifestyle did crystal meth even do
anything for you after even on it it
just makes me feel more energetic I I
feel like I need energy a lot of the
times because I'm so depressive
so I'm sure you get thoughts of
depression yes
has it always been the case
uh that most most times more than not
yes I get depressed especially living
alone abandoning strange cities where I
don't know family or friends
I've been here three years and honestly
I couldn't tell you five or six people's
names that I would talk to on a daily
basis
and I don't I don't talk to no one I go
home to myself and
um sit at home in my apartment and it's
it's a sad life that I'm living and I
would like to come out of it honestly
not not to die or anything but to to
live better a little better yeah yeah I
come I come out here because I'm a
singer I sing country music and Regular
Music hip hip hop a little bit
and um I have a problem with putting my
lyrics to music
so that's I come out here to try to do
something with that and I haven't had
the the time or the patience nor the
money to do so you know do you have any
friends
not here
what would you
what would you suggest to somebody else
who's
struggling with similar problems
don't don't give up and don't be afraid
to talk about it
um it's emotional it hurts but to
release the emotions it's it's helped me
a lot and people may look at you like
you're you're a big baby or that you
you're you can't control your own life
but to cry as a man or to cry as a young
lady
our older lady is it helps you get in
tune with who you are it's good to feel
empathy for yourself and your
surroundings it does it opens up your
mind to a whole new plane of existence
because if you can do that then you know
that you're you're worth something more
than what you've been doing living on
the streets is a very degrading it is
existence it is I was um I I sold myself
for sex in Florida a lot and it brought
me down really low really low um almost
to where I was at the point of suicide
so I I had to take a step back from that
life and move and are you gay or bi I'm
I'm gay you're gay yeah
what do you think people don't
understand about
this whole lifestyle drugs and the
street life
well there's people outside of us if
you've always had
um
what you need whether you're a drug
addict or not
um say your family has money and they
just always give you the money you don't
know what a life on the streets is like
it's um because my I came from a little
bit of money and then when my mom passed
and my dad passed um it really took me a
step back and to see that my family they
just said Brian we're not there for you
anymore you're not there for yourself
we're gonna have to do tough love and
not be there for you and that's the way
it is to this very day I don't call them
and they don't call me and I'm missing
out on family reunions um my little
brother going to college
just all the things that my family back
in Alabama and Tennessee are doing and
I'm not a part of it because I took a
step off of my track and just kept on
what was the norm for me which was drugs
and I've lost out on a lot of my little
brother's life and I'm 15 years older
than him
and with my mom being gone and his
father now his father's gone my father
passed in 95 so it's we need to be
closer together than further apart as we
are do you understand their side of it
where they're just choosing tough love I
do but when you're at that point in your
life like even if I was sober at that
point and I called my aunt or called
someone in my family can you please send
me some money for a bus ticket so I can
get home so I can come back home they're
just I'm at that point with them to
where they're like no we're not helping
you with anything we're not even
answering your phone calls so that's
where I'm at with my family and so if
you're ever there with your family if
anyone ever sees this that can relate to
what I'm talking about
prove to them get yourself
um like I'm I'm doing get in an
apartment start going to work and prove
to them show up in your own vehicle and
show show them that you can make
something out of your life and be able
to applicate yourself back into your
family role it's something that we all
need is family so
what's been your darkest Point Florida
yeah
yeah I was actually shot in Florida
um I was at a gas station and I was
getting it I was I had a lottery ticket
and I came across the road and I got in
the wrong pickup truck on the there was
some people and a wife Ford or a white
four-door pickup and when the speakers
like when someone's talking with their
cell phone on the speakers it sounds
like sometimes it's outside the vehicle
well they were saying Brian and then so
I thought they were talking to me and I
sat down in the back of the truck I was
like hey how are y'all doing it was two
people in the front and so I opened up
the back door and I sat down and I said
hey what's up because it sounded like
they were saying my name this lady got
out and she had her cell phone in her
hand and a guy got out and he had a gun
in his hand and she's hitting me with a
cell phone and he brings out the gun and
shot me and that was one of the lowest
points in my life that was just a
miscommunication it was miscommunication
and that was I was up at 2 A.M in the
morning going to a a gas station for a
lottery ticket that I wasn't even sure
was a winner because I was probably
wanting to get some drugs or something
you know and I was I was so strung out
at that time I'm looking at lottery
tickets and I'm like okay so if I can
just line it up this way it I can just
prove that it's a winner or something
like this and that's what drugs to do to
you it'll get you in a psychosis to
where you're not yourself and and that's
one of the major downfalls of drugs is
the psychosis that comes along with it
what do you think the biggest
factor is going to be now for you to
kind of get your life back together
to be stable
um to get a stable income other than
food stamps and then reach back out to
my family I right now don't even have a
cell phone that's working and I'm gonna
go and try to get back in touch with
them and let them know you know I'm
doing fine then I'm out here in
California they knew they know I'm here
but I just haven't talked to them in
probably over a year yeah because of
what they want to hear from you is that
you're that I'm doing better yeah
housing that you have a job that you're
not using drugs all that kind of stuff
yep um that's that's mainly what I would
like to do is reach out to them and tell
them I'm still doing fine but I'm not at
the point to where I would like to
share my life with them yet I'm still
not at that point yet
what would you say is the most important
lesson you've learned in your life
loss of loss of life
um people who you love and that's been
taken from you that's been the most
important lesson that I've learned is
cherish the moments you have with who
you love
thank you so much for sharing your story
thank you I wish you the best of luck
thank you so much